okay chef Derwin hmm not quite right
what why are you rewriting the book bozo
Dianne's version is great
you're gonna lose gems like this one and
I am the only long-standing relationship
in bojack's life is with his agent
Princess Carolyne her loyalty must come
from a deep-rooted faith that she's
talented enough to sustain the career of
a man society perceives as a joke yeah I
would say that I'm not such a fan of
that one all publicity is good publicity
that guy who killed all those teachers
and ate their fingers he just got
married in jail and when this book comes
out you could be that guy don't you get
it
this is my last chance to make people
love me again if this goes out
everybody's gonna see the real me
now I spent a lot of time with the real
me and believe me nobody's gonna love
that guy oh okay now if you'll excuse me
I need to go take a shower so I can't
tell if I'm crying or not
all right let's get to work
I feel like we can beat this font ah
copperplate a bunt for the truly modern
man nope
there you are very Dada Oh Comic Sans
you want to go home
3:10 you spent six hours playing with
bonds holy well this can't be that
hard
Bojack often felt the need to impress me
with material items you can see from the
teeny tiny brushstrokes that this is
very expensive I wondered where this
came from there were two obvious
suspects his mother Beatrice heiress to
the Sugarman Sugarcubes fortune and used
to certain comforts and his
working-class father butterscotch
horseman who often failed to provide
those comforts or maybe it was something
even
[Music]